ROBERT: So welcome to "Up Close
and Personal," with NFC
and Android Beam.
This is Martin, and
I'm Robert.
We both work on the NFC and
Beam team on Android.
And we're going to tell you
about NFC and Beam.
Everyone is in the right
session, yeah?
This is a good time to leave
if you don't want to get
really excited about NFC.
Cool.
Martin, take it away.
MARTIN: Let's get started.
All right, so a show of hands,
how many of you guys actually
know what NFC is?
Wow, that's almost all of you.
Just for the few of you who
don't, we're actually going to
go through a few slides to
explain what exactly the
technology is, and what
it does, what's
so great about it.
So NFC stands for Near
Field Communication.
And basically, it's a wireless
technology very much like
Bluetooth or Wi-Fi.
However, there are a few key
differences to NFC from these
technologies.
So one of the main differences
is that NFC
is very short range.
So it just works over a distance
of a few centimeters
instead of the meters
that you're used to
from Wi-Fi or Bluetooth.
We actually think short range is
a great feature of NFC, and
we'll show you more
in a moment.
Another difference between NFC
and the other wireless
technologies is that it has
a fairly low data rate.
So the typical data rates for
NFC are a few hundred kilobits
per second, not more.
So you don't want to be
sending too much data
over NFC at a time.
A few kilobytes is
a good maximum.
And a final thing about NFC
that's different from the
other wireless technologies
is that it's
really no setup at all.
So over the Bluetooth, when you
want to do something, you
always have to enter a PIN,
you have to do pairing.
It's really annoying to
get stuff set up.
The great thing with NFC is that
when you bring devices
into range, immediately, they
set up a connection, and they
can start talking
to each other.
So you don't need to do any
pairing, no PIN setup, it just
immediately works.
So when you have NFC on your
device, what can you actually
do with it?
So I think there's two main
use cases of NFC.
And the first one you see on
the left, which is what we
call passive tags.
Passive tags are small
form factor devices.
They come in lots of form
factors, but they are
typically the size of a credit
card, sometimes a bit smaller.
And they're often stickers, so
you can put them onto stuff.
And their main function
is really to store a
small amount of data.
Most tags can store a few
kilobytes of data.
So what you can typically put
into a tag is a simple set of
data like a URL to a website,
a link to a YouTube video, a
vCard for a contact that
you know about.
Now what makes these tags really
special is that they
don't require any power.
And that is where the passive
comes from, in the name.
So you don't need to put
any battery in these.
Whenever you put an NFC-powered
device on top of
this tag, the NFC field in your
phone will power the tag,
power it on, and allow it to
read the data from the tag.
The other thing about tags is
that you can often reprogram
them as well, so they'll
write many times.
So you can write it once, and
if you decide you want store
something else on it, you can
just overwrite it and put
whatever you want on it.
And the second thing
about them is that
they're also lockable.
So in case you do really want to
finalize the data that you
have on the tag, you can lock
them to make sure that nobody
can overwrite your tags,
which is great for
a lot of use cases.
Now the second way to interact
you see on the right.
So you typically have, like,
two powered NFC devices.
So an example is if you have two
phones, or a phone and a
tablet, that both have NFC,
when you bring these two
devices together, they
can immediately start
communicating to each other.
Now the main difference between
this and tags is that
with tags, you typically store
a set of data on it, and it's
a static amount of data.
Whereas when you put two active
devices together, you
can change the data dynamically
from the
application that you want.
And that's one of the main use
cases of Android Beam that
we'll show you later.
Another use case that you
probably all have seen here at
the conference is Google Wallet,
where you put your
phone up to a payment reader,
and you can do payment.
So I do really want to go into
the 5 centimeters thing
because that's something that
I really hear a lot.
People think this is a
limitation of NFC.
I think this is the greatest
feature of NFC and what makes
it really great.
So imagine you're in a room
full of smart devices.
Like you have a room with
a Nexus Q and a Nexus 7.
And you maybe have a Smart TV
in there, even a bottle of
wine which has an
NFC tag on it.
How do you determine which
device you're going to
interact with?
Well, the easy answer is
just by touching it.
So if you want to interact with
the Nexus Q, tap your
Nexus Q. If you want to interact
or get data from the
bottle of wine, tap the
bottle of wine.
And it may show you the
manufacturing info about it.
So this allows you to be really
specific about the way
you interact with stuff.
So this is one of the main use
cases, you know, touching
physical objects for digital
interaction.
And the other use case comes
from actually having two
active devices.
So if you have two phones, you
can have a virtual object on
one of these phones.
A virtual object can be like
a URL or a business card.
You can just beam it across.
And you can be really
selective about
where you send it to.
And this is really great about
short range-- it allows you to
be selective about
how you interact
with different devices.
I'll hand it over to Robert
to talk a bit more about
different NFC use cases.
ROBERT: Thanks.
So what can you do with NFC?
Well, we've got a list here on
the slide which I won't read
because you can all see it.
But these are really just
the usual suspects.
Whenever you read a report about
the future of NFC, all
of these use cases come up.
But there's going to be
lots of new things.
Martin introduced the idea of
peer to peer, two active NFC
devices communicating
with each other.
And as many new phones come
equipped with that capability,
we're going to see lots and
lots of new NFC use cases.
Also, applications which use
NFC to share are going to
drive this, and it's all going
to get much more interesting.
We really think of NFC as
being very, very simple.
It is a very simple
technology.
It doesn't actually
do a whole lot.
When you think about it, HTTP
doesn't do a whole lot,
either, but HTTP enabled the
web and all of the amazing
things you can do
with the web.
So don't be fooled by the
simplicity of NFC.
We think that's actually where
its raw power comes from.
We want to keep it simple.
It's a very basic technology,
but when you start to use it,
then you can start to harness
the power, and you can really
get imaginative.
And we really do think the
limits of NFC are just the
limits of your imagination.
The other question people often
have is, well, when is
NFC going to happen?
We think it's already here.
Don't wait too long, you really
should get started.
And it's great to see so many
of you here today interested
in NFC and wanting
to learn more.
If you were in the keynote
yesterday, does anybody
remember what the number was
for the number of Android
devices activated with
NFC every week?
No, no one remembers,
thank you.
OK, a million, thank you.
Yes, it is a million new Android
devices, every week,
activated with NFC that have
all of these capabilities.
And it's moving into low- and
mid-end, low-range and
mid-range devices.
It isn't just the high-end
phones that have NFC now.
So let's take a closer look
because this is going to come,
now, not just in phones and
other devices but in
accessories.
And we're going to show
you that later on.
Lots and lots of smart objects,
maybe not quite the
bottle of wine that Martin
mentioned earlier.
But let's take a closer look at
what you can do on Android.
Android provides a framework for
NFC so that you can create
whatever your application
and your users need.
And as it says on the slide,
we support all the common
passive tag types, we have APIs,
and you can even launch
an application using NFC, more
of which in a little while.
But we think tags are
just the start.
NFC, as it becomes more
widespread, is going to bring
magic to this platform.
Let's take a look
at Android Beam.
Android Beam enables
magic sharing.
It makes it really, really
easy for you to give your
users a magical experience.
It's deliberately very, very
simple, with almost no UI.
There's nothing to it.
And again, we'll show
you more about that.
All you have to do is bring the
two devices together with
their screens unlocked.
That's important, we want users
to stay in control here.
This is a personal device, the
screen has to be unlocked, the
phone has to be on for NFC and
for Android Beam to work.
Whoever wants to share just taps
on the screen to confirm
that they're happy for the
information to be sent.
And the context from their
application, normally what's
shown on the screen,
gets beamed across
to the other device.
It really is that simple.
There are no menus, there
are no dialogue boxes.
There's nothing to
get in the way.
And that's why we have that
"Touch to Beam," just to make
it very, very easy.
So let's take a look
at some of this in
action with some demos.
So we'll switch over so we
can see our devices here.
So as we've said, it's really,
really easy to share content.
On my phone here, I've got an
interesting article, which I
probably should share with you
because it contains some
fascinating news.
This is from People magazine,
one of my favorite websites.
And, as the Wi-Fi loads, you'll
see it's an article,
there we go, about Prince
William and
his $16 million fortune.
Not sure about his
dress sense, but
we'll leave that aside.
No wonder Kate's laughing
in the background.
But if I wanted to read this
on my tablet, got a Nexus 7
here, it's very easy.
All I would do, put the phone
down, Touch to Beam, and, in
just a second or two, it's
already open on the tablet.
And once again, as you know, the
Wi-Fi's a little bit slow
here, but it's going to bring
in the article in People
magazine very, very quickly.
I can do exactly the
same-- come on.
You can see the URL's
gone across.
It works.
We're now waiting for Wi-Fi,
but that's Beam.
It is very, very simple.
This doesn't bode well for the
YouTube demo, if we cannot get
a web page to load.
But let's give it
a shot anyway.
So I've got YouTube running on
this phone, and I was going to
show video from the Android
keynotes last year.
But let's keep on rolling.
What YouTube does is it actually
starts the video
playing at exactly the same spot
on the receiving device.
So if you're halfway through
a movie or halfway through
something, it'll
take you there.
It's very easy for you to skip
back to the start if that's
what you wanted, rather than
fiddling around to try to find
the playhead.
So again, we're transferring
the context of the app from
one device to the other.
So his demo that doesn't
rely on Wi-FI
because we're not stupid--
it is the Moscone Center, and
Wi-Fi's always tough here.
So I've got a great app on my
Android device called Paper
Camera, which lets me take
nice, creative photos.
So I'm going to grab a picture
of you guys looking awesome.
Here we go.
And I'm going to change-- we're
going to make it look
like you're drawn
in aqua pastels.
So that's how I roll.
So I've got my aqua
pastel photo.
Martin, oh, you haven't
got Paper Camera.
MARTIN: No, it looks pretty
cool, though.
ROBERT: It is pretty cool.
Let's see what happens when I
beam an app from this device
to a device that doesn't
have the app installed.
So I just Tap to Beam, and when
Martin flips over, you
see it's gone to
the Play store.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT: Thank you, so Beam
is a distribution
mechanism for your apps.
And that's automatic.
You don't have to
write any code.
Every Android app will do that
when two Beam-compatible
phones come together.
So what's happening now--
once again, relying
on the Wi-Fi which--
so we'll move on.
A bit like a cookery show, we've
got one in the oven we
made earlier.
And so we've now got
Paper Camera
installed on another device.
MARTIN: Yep, let's
try this one.
ROBERT: And I'm going to snap
another photo, but aqua-tint
didn't really work for me.
So I'm going to switch to my
favorite, which is Andy Pop.
Now, Paper Camera's
a great app, and
it's got lots of settings.
So I can grab this photo,
which I've now
played around with.
Let's see what happens when I
beam-- so Martin, let's get
your Paper Camera.
Let's just have a look.
Your, so--
MARTIN: I haven't launched
it yet, but it'll launch
automatically.
ROBERT: You haven't
launched it yet.
OK, so there's my settings.
I've got Andy Pop running.
So I'm going to beam
that across.
Put my phone the right
way up, sorry.
And what's going to happen
now, because the app is
installed, you see Paper Camera
has opened in Andy Pop.
So the exact context from this
device, the setting-- so if
Martin thinks, "Wow, how do
you get that cool effect,"
we've passed the information
across, so it makes it really,
really easy.
A lot of games developers
are using that to
start two-player games.
So if I'm at the start of a game
on my device and want to
play head-to-head against
someone else-- just tap the
phones, start a head-to-head
connection.
So pretty cool uses of Android
Beam for peer-to-peer sharing.
Martin's going to show us,
now, some tag behaviors.
MARTIN: Yeah, some really cool
stuff you can do with tags is
you can just stick them
in all kinds of weird
places that you like.
A really cool use case, if you
want to show off something
like, for example, you're
holding a representation at a
cool conference like Google
I/O. You want to tell
people about it.
So what you can do is you can
hang posters all around the
buildings for your presentation,
for example, a
poster that looks like this
one for our presentation.
And you can put all kinds
of data in there.
So in this case, I put a data
in there that links along to
the Google I/O application.
So that whenever somebody taps
this tag, it will actually
take you to the Google I/O
application and immediately
show you the session that
we're having right here.
It shows you more information.
You can interact with it,
add it to your agenda.
ROBERT: And again, what would
have happened there if you
didn't have the app installed?
MARTIN: So if I didn't have the
app installed, it would've
taken me to Market first, to
install the application.
ROBERT: Cool.
MARTIN: Awesome.
So I'm sure you all saw the
really cool keynote yesterday
where they showed off the new
Google+ events use case.
I think it was really cool, and
it showed different kinds
of events and what you can
do with Android Beam.
So let's say we're having a
beach barbecue that we're
organizing.
If you go to Google+ events, you
probably know the people
you want to invite.
Well, let's say you want to
have a surprise party.
For example, I'm not sure if you
guys saw the movie Project
X, but it was like--
it really got out of hand
because a lot of people showed
up that weren't supposed
to show up.
Let's say you put a poster here
for a beach barbecue,
somewhere in your dorm room or
in a building somewhere.
People can actually tag this
poster with their phone.
And wha it does is it just
brings you to Google Maps to
show you the actual location
of where the
party is going to happen.
Now if the Wi-Fi was
actually-- oh,
it's pretty good now.
It's showing it's at Sunside
Beach, so this is where you're
going to have the party.
You chose a pretty
good location.
ROBERT: Yeah, so we've got the
exact location, so we can make
sure the skydivers
arrive on time.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT: The bar has
been raised.
It's not a party without
skydivers, guys.
MARTIN: So a really cool final
use case about tags that I
want to share with you is,
actually, that you can couple
tags to do actions on your
device, so for example, on
your phone or your tablet.
Now, for example, you can
associate a sticker that you
put on your bedstand with muting
the volume or launching
a different application.
Or you can have a sticker in
your office that disconnects
the Wi-Fi and does different
kinds of settings.
Now there are a few cool
applications in Android Market
already that allow you to
configure a tag to execute
certain operations
on your phone.
And one of the applications I'm
going to show you is NFC
Task Launcher, which allows
you to do just that.
So in this application,
you define a new tag.
And for each tag you can define
a number of tasks that
you want to be executed whenever
you touch this tag.
So let's say I want to create a
task for when I go to Google
I/O. I think one of the things
I want to do when I get here
is, you know, launch the Google
I/O application to see
what sessions I'm going
to go to today.
I probably want to mute the
volume to make sure that,
during the sessions, I don't
interrupt anything.
Now, so let's add an action.
I can add an action to launch
an application.
And for the application,
I'm going to select
the Google I/O app.
OK, I can add as many
actions as I like.
So I can add another action
related to the volume.
I can say the ring
tone volume.
I can configure it.
In this case, I'll just set
it to mute, all right.
So now I have two actions.
I can press finish.
And the next thing I have to do
is I just need to have an
empty tag, like this one.
I can put it under my phone,
touch the phone, and it writes
the data to the tag.
So what's going to happen now is
that, whenever I touch this
tag, it's going to execute
these actions.
So we just to find a good
place for this tag.
Why don't we use your badge?
ROBERT: Yeah, sure, so I've got
my badge, which has one of
those old-fashioned
QR codes on.
[LAUGHTER]
MARTIN: Yeah, it doesn't
really work very well.
Let's do it like this.
So now, whenever you touch
this tag with any of your
phones, what it's going to do,
it's going to launch the
Google I/O application,
and it's going to set
the volume to mute.
So you can have all kinds of
cool actions associated with
each of these tags.
You just stick them on all the
places that you like--
ROBERT: But you programmed
that--
that could be a trick.
Because you programmed that.
MARTIN: Oh sure, want to
try a real device?
ROBERT: Does it only
work on your phone?
There we go.
So I can go in there, and is
it going to set my volume?
MARTIN: Let's do it
with this phone.
This'll work.
It does the same.
ROBERT: Awesome.
MARTIN: Cool.
ROBERT: And it auto-launches
the app, cool.
Now, actually, all of the things
we've shown you are
possible today with Ice
Cream Sandwich.
But we announced Jelly Bean
yesterday, and we've got some
new, exciting NFC features.
We've added new features to J,
which we'll be able to tell
you a little bit about today,
which we think will be very
exciting for users and for
accessory manufacturers, all
of the people who make
accessories to work with
phones and devices.
One of the great things about
all of these devices is-- you
know, they're wireless, they can
connect over Bluetooth--
but every time on Bluetooth, you
need a PIN, you've got to
have 1234, you've got to have
0000, and it's a pain.
With NFC you can just
tap to pair.
So Martin's got his headphones
on ready, and I've got my
phone here.
So I've got some
music on here.
So let's see what happens when
I tap my phone up here.
And it says it's connecting
to the headphones.
And music should start
any second.
So Martin's rocking out,
but hang on, hang on,
let's bring him back.
And disconnecting,
simple as that.
You're a tough--
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT: Yeah, thank you, yeah.
Tough crowd.
Actually, that is a bit of a
cheap demo because Martin is
perfectly capable of pretending
to dance.
So we got these speakers,
which are just the same,
NFC-powered.
And, you know, after a busy day
at Google I/O, I've been
partying, want to come, keep
the party rocking.
I just take my phone--
[MUSIC PLAYING - KRISS
KROSS, "JUMP"]
ROBERT: All right, really,
really easy, and--
[MUSIC STOPS]
ROBERT: --when we've had enough
Kriss Kross, easy to
get rid of them.
So once again, NFC making
pairing by Bluetooth, that was
creating a Bluetooth connection,
completely
transparent to the user.
Taking advantage of that 5
centimeters just so that you
can come and tap and
make things happen,
really, really easy.
So we got rid of those horrible
PINs that used to
slow you down.
So let's have a look at another
area that could be
improved by getting
rid of PINs.
Let's talk about the future of
file-sharing between devices.
So, quick question, how many of
you have transferred a file
between two devices using
Bluetooth in the last year?
So about, maybe, I think that's
about a fifth, a fifth
of the hands.
In the last month?
Yeah, a few hardcore
masochists.
And in the last week?
So kind of no one.
You've been having way too much
fun here to be messing
around with Bluetooth
file transfer.
And if you look all the steps
that it takes to achieve
Bluetooth file transfer, it's
not really surprising.
So let's have a look at
the future of sharing.
So I'm going to take a
quick picture of you.
I'll do this side,
just to be fair.
I don't want you feeling
left out.
So there we go.
So I've got a picture of you,
which is on my phone now.
So let's see what happens.
MARTIN: Switch them
on for you?
ROBERT: Yeah, thank
you Martin.
So, sorry, you need to be able
to see what we're doing.
So I've got that picture here.
And when I tap to beam it
over, let's see what's
happening on Martin's
phone now.
So he has a notification that
there's an incoming beam.
And even though that file is a
few hundred k, and the phones
aren't now within NFC
range, you can see
it's doing the transfer.
So this is much, much easier.
So as that completes, it may
take a few more seconds
because it's quite a big file
from a Galaxy Nexus camera.
MARTIN: Yeah, several megabytes
from the camera.
ROBERT: Yes, several megs.
So how did that happen?
Well, the good news is, as you
saw there, it's absolutely
transparent to the user.
There's no steps, there's no
confirmation, just the usual
Beam behavior.
This supports photos
and videos.
What we're actually doing is
initiating, using NFC, the
Bluetooth file transfer.
So we automatically pair the
devices in the background.
We don't need the user to
confirm because they've used
Beam to confirm.
And automatically, there
we go, it's completed.
So Martin can show
that now just to
show we're not cheating.
MARTIN: It's saying
"Beam complete."
Just have to tap it.
ROBERT: And there's a photo.
So how easy was that.
And that will work--
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT: Thank you.
So that's a new public
API for you to use.
And it can be any payload.
These are just the payloads
that are built in.
So your apps can take advantage
of this too.
So we've show you
some cool demos.
Let's go on to talk about how we
think you might want to use
NFC in your applications.
And we're excited that many of
you are already doing that.
Here are some reasons why
it can be useful to
add NFC to your app.
Well, users love NFC.
It's so easy and natural, you
just tap things together and
stuff starts to happen.
It really feels magical, it's
like being in a movie.
You can just walk up to things
and make stuff happen.
It really does give
you that kind of
Minority Report feeling.
The good news is, you can make
users feel good like that in
just a few lines of code.
This isn't a big effort
for you guys.
It's really simple to add it.
We're very lucky that we have
so many thousands of great
developers like you guys
building for Android.
But we know it can be hard to
make your app stand out.
Taking advantage of these new
features makes life easy for
your users and it can help your
app to do well and to
perform and to get
users excited.
Let's take a quick look
at the opportunities.
We think there's kind of two
ways to look at NFC.
When you're doing things with
tags, the kind of stuff Martin
showed, you know, putting a
poster up, putting a sticker
up by the light switch in your
home to change your behaviors,
maybe, of your phone, you're
probably thinking about new
applications and new use cases,
things that you didn't
necessarily do before.
And there's lots of
documentation on the web about
how to do that.
And people think about, you
know, games in the real world,
where you have to go around
collecting tags to prove
you've been in a place,
and things like that.
If you already have a successful
app on Android in
the Play store, what we think
you should try to think about
is, where in the app do your
users have something they
might want to share?
Where might they want to share
the context or the content
between two devices?
Because Beam is a great
way to do that.
Beam isn't really about
new use cases.
We were talking to a developer
yesterday, and he said, well,
all it does is share content
from one device to another.
Well, yeah.
We thought that was
pretty good.
It doesn't have to
make the tea.
It just share content from
one device to another.
And that, kind of, is
the point about it.
So for the rest of the
presentation, we're going to
focus on Beam and how
to share content and
context between devices.
And at first, you may not
think that your app has
anything to share.
Maybe you don't take photos
or create new content.
But just like we showed with
Paper Camera, almost every app
has some state that might be
complex to set up, you know,
there's many settings.
Think about what's useful
to move from
one person to another.
But also, just think about the
fact that many people have
more than one NFC-enabled
device.
All of you now have several.
You might be looking at
something on your phone, you
want to look at it on a tablet,
you want to make play
on a Nexus Q, for example.
It's very, very natural
to beam from
one device to another.
So it isn't always about
one person to another.
It could just be the same person
who's come into the
room, or changed context, or
picked up another device.
So before I hand over to Martin
to show you how to make
this magic and add it to your
applications, I want to point
out a couple of pitfalls
with Android Beam.
We tried to make it really
magical, and in a few cases,
we've seen some apps that make
us a little bit sad.
Because they've, somehow,
managed to break Beam.
And when you break Beam,
a kitten dies.
It really is that simple.
So please don't break Beam.
Well, how do you break Beam?
Usually by adding
something to it.
And we're not going to name
names today, because we
wouldn't do that, because we
love all of our developers.
But here are some of the
things we've seen done.
We've seen somebody put
Beam on a menu.
So over on the right-hand side
there, you see, on the slide,
it's like, oh I want
to share now.
The user tells your app they
want to share using Beam by
putting it next to
another device.
They don't go and choose
from a menu.
They shouldn't have
to do that.
That proximity is your
cue to share.
And when Martin comes on to talk
about it the APIs, you'll
see how you can even be very
late-binding and only declare
your payload at the time when
you're in close proximity with
another device.
So please don't put
it on a menu.
Please don't add other
dialogues.
In the middle there, you've got
a pop-up that we've seen
in apps that says "Are you
sure you want to share?"
Again, how often do you put
your phone within 5
centimeters of someone
else's phone?
It's a very deliberate act.
You do not need to click and
say, "yes, I'm absolutely
sure."
So those are all ways,
we think, you can
chase the magic away.
So please don't do that.
And please just leave Beam be.
It's not perfect.
We're always going to add new
things, and we're going to
talk at the end about a few
ideas about where we might go.
But for now, just try
and keep it simple.
So I don't want to dwell anymore
on how to do it wrong.
I'm going to hand it over to
Martin to show you how you can
add the magic of Beam sharing
into your apps.
MARTIN: Cool.
So let's take a look
at how our Beam
share works in detail.
So let's say you have two
devices, device A and device
B, and you want to send
something across from device A
to device B. Now let's say that
your application is the
one that's running
on device A.
As you know, Android
applications basically consist
of a number of activities.
What you developers have to
decide is, for each activity,
does it make sense to
share anything over
Beam for this activity?
And if so, what is that?
And once you've determined that,
you have to use a few
set of simple APIs to tell the
Android operating system about
the data that you want to share
from this activity.
So what happens next is that
whenever you bring the two
devices in range, the Android
operating system is going to
check which activity is running
in the foreground now.
Once it has determined that,
it'll see that for the
application in the foreground,
is there anything registered
that they want to
send over Beam?
And in case there is, once you
touch the button to send,
it'll automatically send
the payload across.
So on the receiving side, you
get the data over NFC.
And, basically, what we do with
any incoming NFC data is
we try to start an activity
to deal with the data.
So we somehow have to resolve
the NFC data that's incoming
to an activity.
And we'll go into more detail on
each of these steps later.
So first, I want to share more
about the data format that you
use for sharing over NFC.
And the data format
is called NDEF.
So let's first go a bit
more into detail about
NDEF and how it works.
So NDEF stands for the NFC
Data Exchange Format.
And it's basically a simple
message format that was
defined by the NFC forum,
which is like the NFC
standards organization.
And it's backed by all the
major industry players.
And NDEF has, really,
two basic types.
One type is the NDEF message,
and the other entity type is
an NDEF record.
Now an NDEF message
is really simple.
It's nothing more or less than
one or more NDEF records.
So it's just an encapsulation
of multiple NDEF records.
And what is an NDEF record?
An NDEF record consists,
basically, of a
single set of data.
So a single NDEF record can
be something like a URI.
It can be a vCard, it
can be a link to a
place on Google Maps.
You can have multiple of these
records in a message.
Now once you go inside a record,
let's see what fields
it's composed of.
Now the first field in an NDEF
record is called the Type Name
Format or the TNF field.
And all the Type Name Format
field does is tell the
interpreter how to interpret
the second field in the
message, the Type field.
So there are a few distinct
values that you can use in the
TNF field, and each of those
changes the way that the type
field is interpreted.
You can see some examples
on the right.
If you use a Type Name Format
value of 1, which stands for
the WELL_KNOWN type, and for the
Type, you can actually use
a few short byte values.
For example, if you specify the
Type as 55 hex, that means
it's a URI.
And the reason why this is good
is that you only use two
bytes in the process of
specifying which type of
record this is.
So this is a lot easier than
actually spelling out the MIME
type in text, right?
Remember, NFC is low data rate,
so you don't want to
waste too many bytes.
So WELL_KNOWN is what you use
to have a few well-known
record types and be able to
encode it in one or two bytes.
Now a different Type Name
Format is, for example,
MIME_MEDIA.
When you specify Type Name
Format as MIME_MEDIA, value 2
in the TNF field, that means
that the Type field will be
interpreted as the
MIME type of the
packet that you're sending.
So then in the Type field, you
can put a string, for example,
saying text/plain, which is a
MIME type for your record.
Next, there's an optional
identifier.
Most people actually don't
use the identifier.
You can put any bytes in
there that you want.
But the Android operating system
doesn't actually do
anything with it, so it's
purely optional.
And the final part
is the important
part, that's the payload.
So in the payload, you
put the actual data
that you want to share.
So in case you want to share an
URI, in the payload would
be the actual data of
the URI itself.
So how do you create such a
message for the Android APIs
that we have?
Well, there's a few
ways to do it.
And the first way is
we do the hard way.
So we have the constructor on
the NdefRecord, for which you
can specify all for the fields
of the NdefRecord.
So the first field is the
TNF field, in this case
WELL-KNOWN, the second
one is URI, Type URI.
You can specify an ID and
get the bytes of it.
And finally, you can get the
actual payload in it and put
the bytes in there.
Now, because a lot of people
just want to have some
standard records like URIs, we
actually created some helper
methods on the NdefRecord
clause.
So instead of using this complex
constructor, you can
use a lot easier way.
Simply call
NdefRecord.createURI.
And as the only argument,
you have to specify the
URI that you want.
And it will automatically
create a record for you.
So the second statement is
equivalent to the first one.
Now another helper that we have
is if you want to create
your own custom MIME type.
So NdefRecord.createMime allows
you to specify, as a
first argument, the MIME type
of your record, and as a
second argument, the payload
that you have.
So this way, again, you don't
need to use a constructor.
You just have to pass in these
two values, and you're done.
Now once you've put in the
NdefRecords that you want and
put in the message, all you
have to do is call the
NdefMessage constructor, and
as an argument, you can
specify one or more
NdefRecords.
In this case, I just created a
message with a single record,
which is the URI record that
I created earlier.
So one of the things you might
ask when you see these slides
is, well, how do I know which
type I should use?
And I think one of the
guidelines is that if you use
an existing type, for example,
if you were to use text/plain,
which indicates text type, then
any applications on the
receiving device that already
have or handle this MIME type
will be able to handle
this payload as well.
So this allows you to reuse
implications that can deal
with your payload.
On the other hand,
you may have some
very specific payloads.
For example, there's
something that only
your app can interpret.
In that case, you may want to
have to, like, a MIME type
that's specific for
your application.
And in some cases, you
know, it's a hybrid.
Maybe in some cases, you have
an image that you want to
share, or even a text file,
but you still want a very
specific applications
to handle it.
And we don't think you should
be going and hacking around
MIME types.
In that case, we created a
special NDEF record for
specifically that use case.
And that record is called the
Android Application Record.
So what the Android Application
Record does is if
you put in a message, it will
guarantee delivery of the
message to the package
that you specify.
So you can create an Android
Application Record which
specifies package com dot
Google dot whatever, and
whenever this message is
received on the other side,
the operating system will make
sure that that's the package
that handles the message.
Now you can even put multiple
records that represent
multiple packages in
an NDEF message.
So you can say, well, as a
first preference, I want
application A to handle this
payload, but if it's not
available, then please do
it by application B.
And the other final thing to
understand is that even if in
the application that you
specify, it doesn't even do
anything with NFC, it doesn't
handle NFC intents, it will
still be launched.
So it's still, if you create
an NDEF message with an
Android Application Record, it's
also an easy way for you
to launch an application on a
remote device, even if that
application does not
support NFC at all.
And the final thing to know
about Android Application
Records is that if the receiving
device is not have
the application installed at
all, it'll take you to the
Play store, where you can
actually install the
application immediately, which
is what we saw before.
So just to show you how to build
an Android Application
Record, we also have a helper
method for that as well.
So all you have to do is, you
create a URI record like we
did before.
And initially, you create an
Android Application Record by
calling createApplicationRecord.
And the only argument have to
give is the package name of
the package that you want to
handle the payload on the
receiving side.
And now you simply compose an
NDEF message by specifying
these two records.
So the first record is
uriRecord, and the second
record this the Android
Application Record.
And this'll make sure that the
URI payload goes to the
application that you specified,
pretty easy.
So once you've built the NDEF
message, how, now, do you tell
the Android operating system for
which activity you want to
pass this message?
Well, there's two really simple
APIs that you can use.
So the one that you see
on the top is the
setNdefPushMessage API.
It's a really simple API where
you can just pass in any
activity, and as a second
argument, you
can pass in the message.
Actually, it's the
other way around.
And what this does, basically,
is tell the Android operating
system for this activity,
share this message.
And this is really great if you
have static content for
your activity.
Like your activity is always
sharing the same type of data.
So that's when you want
to use this API.
Now there's a different set of
use cases where the data that
you want your activity to
share actually changes
dynamically during whatever
you're interacting with in the
application.
So in that case, we
actually have a
callback variant as well.
So what you do instead is you
call the setNdefPushMessage
callback method.
You register a callback
with the NFC service.
And whenever somebody brings the
two NFC devices in range,
this callback is called.
You can form the NDEF message
that you want to share, return
it, and it gets sent across
to the other side.
So the second use case is
really easy for dynamic
applications, for example,
Gallery, where the activity
stays the same but the actual
content changes if you swipe
your finger across the screen.
The important thing to know
about the activities that
you're passing into this API is
that you can basically call
this in any activity state as
long as it hasn't been through
the onDestroy call.
So from whenever the moment
you're in onCreate, you can
use this API, until the moment
it's been through onDestroy,
and then it won't
work anymore.
And even though the APIs allow
you to specify multiple
activities, we recommend you
don't do that simply because
for an activity that's not
currently running, you don't
know if it's already been
through onDestroy.
So it's the easiest, in your
applications, to just specify
one activity.
So let's see an actual
implementation.
I have my activity, X,
for which I want to
share an NDEF message.
So in my onCreate, I simply have
to get a reference to the
NFC adapter by calling
a default adapter.
And all I have to do is call
the setNdefPushMessage
callback API, which
I just specified.
The first argument is the
callback, which is actually
also an interface which is
implemented by This clause.
And the second argument is the
activity, which is also This,
in this case.
And then you just need to
implement the / so the
callback is called
createNdefMessage.
And all you need to do in this
callback is create the NDEF
message that you want to be
shared at this moment.
So whenever you bring the
devices together this method
will be called.
You create the NDEF message
that you want to share.
You return it.
And it will be sent
across as soon as
somebody touches the screen.
One thing to note about this
callback is that because it is
called whenever the NFC link
comes up, you don't want to
wait too long or block too
long on this method.
You just want to get the data
ready because the user is
waiting at one point in
time to to touch and
send the data across.
So that's all you have to do for
the sending side, really.
Just specify the data that you
want and tell the Android
operating system, for this
activity, I want
to share this data.
So what happens on the
receiving side?
Well, the receiving side gets an
NDEF message as well in the
NFC service.
And the NFC service somehow has
to translate this message
to an activity that
can handle it.
So how does that work?
This slide shows a bit of code
that's inside the NFC service.
So it's not code that you need
to write yourself, but it's
just there to illustrate how
the NFC service does this.
So when I receive the NDEF
message, it takes a look at
the first record
of the message.
Specifically, it takes look at
the Type Name Format and the
Type fields.
And basically, from these two
fields, it creates a Type that
it sets on intent.
So the first thing it does is
creates a new intent, and the
action on that intent is
ACTION_NDEF_DISCOVERED, to
indicate that it's found
a new NDEF record.
And the second thing it does is
set the Type, based on the
Type Name Format and the Type.
And finally, it puts,
as an extra, the
entire message in it.
So whatever activity is going to
handle the message, it can
actually get the full message
by getting the
extra from the intent.
And then the NFC server simply
calls start activity, and the
normal Android operating system
kicks in to find an
activity that actually matches
these constraints.
So let's take a look at how the
Type Name Format and Type
fields actually are converted
into a Type field in the
intent So we have a few
different records here.
The first is a URI record
of Type WELL_KNOWN.
It shows all of the
NDEF fields.
So the first is TNF, which is
WELL_KNOWN, the second is the
Type, which is the URI type,
the X value that
I showed you earlier.
And the third is the Payload.
So this is going to be
translated to a data field on
the intent.
And the data will be a URI,
http://www.google.com.
Another example is
a text data.
You can also specify text data
by using a TNF of WELL_KNOWN.
Use RTD_TEXT to indicate
that it's a text type.
You can put some text
in the payload.
So this is going to be
translated to an intent type
of text/plain.
And there are a few different
examples on there.
You can also use a
custom MIME type.
And, in this case, your
custom MIME type,
application/vnw.mine, will
end up on the intent.
So it is really a straight
mapping from the Type Name
Format and the Type fields, to
the Type fields, or the Data
field that's in the intent.
So I told you before,
also, about
Android Application Records.
How do they tie into
this picture?
So basically, the code in the
NFC service looks the same for
the first part.
So you will still look
at the first record.
You will determine the Type from
the Type Name Format and
the Type fields.
You'll put the extra, which
has the full NDEF message.
But for each application record
that you find in a
message, you're going
to call the
setPackage API on the intent.
And basically, this tells
Android operating system to
deliver this intent to that
package specifically.
So for each package that's
in there, we first
try to start it.
If it doesn't work, we try the
next one, and so on and so on.
Finally, like I said before, if
you don't find any activity
you either launch the first
application that's in the AAR,
or even if it's not installed,
it takes you to the Play store
to install the application.
Now let's say that you're
interested in
receiving such an intent.
What do you need to do?
Well, it's actually
really simple.
I showed you how the intents
were formed, right?
It's an action with
NDEF_DISCOVERED.
It has a certain Type.
All you need to do is write
an intent filter for your
activity that actually will
filter for this intent and
deal with it.
So in this case, let's say you
have and activity Y, for which
I want to receive a specific
amount of NDEF data, a certain
amount of NDEF data.
Let's look how it works.
Just in the Android manifest,
for the activity Y, I can
specify a few intent filters.
So the first one, for example,
is an intent filter for the
MIME type application/vnw.mine
So the action is the action
NDEF_DISCOVERED, which is what
the NFC service used.
The category is default, as
usual, and you just need to
put in the MIME type that
you want to filter for.
Well, the second example
is on there as well.
If you want to have a URI, for
example, google.com/nfc, you
can put an intent filter.
The action is NDEF_DISCOVERED,
but the data is the scheme you
set, HTTP, and you can put in
the host and the paths to
match exactly what you want.
You can also use wild cards in
there to match different kinds
of patterns.
So once you've done that in the
manifest, all you need to
do is, in your activity that's
handling it, in activity Y, in
this case, you need to get
the actual data and do
something with it.
So in this example, I show you
the onCreate method for your
activity Y. This will get called
by the NFC service.
And basically, what
you do is you just
need to get the intent.
You need to check the action
on the intent to make sure
it's an NDEF_DISCOVERED intent
and not a different one.
Once you know it's that, you can
actually get the payload,
the NDEF message, from it by
just getting the extra out of
the intent.
So you can use the intent dot
getParcelableArrayExtra to get
the extra out.
And then you have the
actual message.
And once you have the message,
you can get the first record.
And from the record, you can
get the actual payload.
So now you actually have the
same payload that the other
side put in into the NDEF
record, and you can start
processing it or do with
it whatever you like.
If it's some big data, you
probably want to do it on a
different thread.
So one of the important things
about receiving, and this is
really, really important to
understand, is that a design
decision we made is that every
NFC interaction that you have
with your device, be it touching
a tag or doing an
Android Beam, it will
launch the activity
in a new task stack.
And the reason for it is that,
you know, we don't really
know, when you tap a tag, was it
really part of the previous
activity that you were doing?
Or is it something
new altogether?
So this is the default behavior
of Android when
launching NFC activities.
It'll just start a
new task stack.
Now for some applications,
that may not make sense.
It may be that your application
always has a
single activity, and you want
it to be launched always in
the same existing task stack.
So let's show you
how it works.
In that case, you can actually
specify for this activity that
the launch mode is
single task.
So what this does is this tells
the Android operating
systems do not create a new
task for this specific NFC
intent but instead to deliver it
to the existing task that's
already running in a separate
task stack.
And the main difference here
is that instead of calling
onCreate and giving you a new
activity, this will actually
call the onNewIntent method,
which allows you to deal with
the NFC data in the activity
while it's already running.
Now there is a final use case
that's important that is if
you have multiple NFC
interactions with multiple
activities.
So the previous slide, that just
showed you one activity,
and you can have multiple NFC
interactions with that, and
for each interaction, you get
a call to onNewIntent.
Well, what if you have
multiple activities?
Well, basically, if multiple
activities have the same
intent filter, that will pop up
the intent or the Activity
Chooser, right?
You've seen that before, if
you open a URL, you choose
between browser and Chrome.
This will also happen for
NFC interactions.
So in this case, what you would
typically do is, you
would typically have an entry
task, where you want to start
interacting with your NFC tag,
or maybe with Android Beam.
And this entry task you would
typically give launch mode
single task, so you make sure
that it routes to an existing
task stack.
Now for all of these subsequent
activities you can
use different a different launch
mode called Single Top,
which means that if that
activity is currently running
on top, your NFC intent will be
delivered to that activity.
And you can combine it
with a feature we
call Foreground Dispatch.
I won't go into too much detail
about it here, but
Foreground Dispatch allows you
to bypass the activity chooser
altogether.
You can say to the Android
operating system, hey, I want
to deal these kinds of intents
or intent filters right now,
and I don't want any other
applications to be
able to handle it.
All right, so let's talk about
some new stuff in J. I'm
really excited about this API
because it brings together a
lot of cool features
and technologies.
So as we've seen before, it's
really hard to get a file from
one device onto another,
right?
As we showed with Bluetooth,
there's lots of screens and
confirmations involved.
So let's take a look at how you
would do this with the new
NFC API in J, which allows you
to share pictures and all
kinds of large data.
So all we have to do is, let's
say I have an activity here.
And in this activity,
I want to share,
like, a URI to a file.
Or I want to share a URI
to a content provider.
I can get a reference
to these URIs.
And all I have to do is call
a single method on the NFC
adapter calling setBeamPushUris.
And in this API call, I
basically specify the URIs
that I want to be sent across
to the other device.
There's also a callback
function in this case.
And this is really all
you need to do.
So once you do this, whenever
you bring the devices into
range, and you tap it, Android
will actually get the data,
send it across to the other side
over Bluetooth, which is
really fast, and it'll deal with
it on the other side and
launch an activity
to handle it.
This is all you need to do.
It's quite amazing, I mean, five
lines of code-- it's so
hard to get a file onto
another device.
You just have to write this,
and all you get is just
instant transfer without any
confirmations or whatever.
It's just like the
Gallery demo that
we showed you before.
So how does it work?
It's pretty simple.
In the flow that we had before,
you have device A and
device B. So on device A, you
just call this API, the
setBeamPushUris API.
And whenever you bring the
devices in range, the NFC
service is going to transfer the
MAC address of the other
device, device B, to device A.
And this allows device A to
set up a background Bluetooth
connection, which allows you
to transfer the data.
So once that's done,
the data is
actually sent over Bluetooth.
The receiving device stores
the data in a file then.
And it launches an ACTION_VIEW
intent to actually deal with
the data on the remote device.
So I want to call this out.
This is different from action
NDEF_DISCOVERED because action
NDEF_DISCOVERED only works on
NDEF data and is specific
specifically to NDEF.
However, there are already a lot
of applications that deal
with the ACTION_VIEW intent
because it's the main intent
that you use for viewing
information.
So that means that whenever you
write some code that does
this, if the receiving side
already has an application
that handles your data, it
will automatically be
launched, which is
really great.
So the great thing about this
API is that you get all the UI
and Bluetooth handling
for free.
So you don't need to write
any Bluetooth code or any
confirmations or whatever.
You just really need to
write a few lines of
code to make it happen.
And the other thing that's
important about it is that you
can use it in combination with
the NDEF APIs that I showed
you before.
So the new API will actually
only work on devices
that have J or late.
So this is important, right?
You want to have a fallback
method in case the device that
you're sending data to doesn't
have the newest implementation
that allows you to
share large data.
So what you can do is you
can use both APIs.
Android will first try to use
the new J way of doing things,
which is sending stuff over
Bluetooth really fast.
If it finds out the other device
doesn't have Bluetooth
or doesn't have the
capability, it'll
fall back to the URI.
So you can still have a fallback
mechanism in case
things don't work.
All right.
Let's wrap up.
I want to share some things
we're thinking
about with you guys.
So what we hear a lot on the
developer forums is that Beam
is really only one-way, right?
You bring the two devices
together, and one of the two
taps, and then data gets sent
across to the other device.
In fact, I think, if you're
really careful with timing,
and you touch right at the
same time, you can get it
going two-way, but that's not
really the way to do it.
So we're really thinking about
supporting two-way
communication in Android Beam
and making sure that once you
bring the devices together, you
can actually ping multiple
messages back and forth
and enable, you know,
much cooler use cases.
You can have all kinds of
protocols going, then.
The other thing we hear a lot
is customizing the Android
Beam animation.
So right now, you see that
whenever you bring the devices
together, the screenshot
scales down.
There's some nice star
field behind it.
Maybe we want to give you some
APIs to actually specify the
screen shot that's shown, that's
being scaled down.
Or maybe you even want to
do your own cool custom
animations.
So that's something we're
definitely looking into.
And the final thing we want to
do is, you know, we have this
great API which allows you to
easily send across large files
over Bluetooth.
And we want to extend it
to use Wi-Fi Direct.
The main reason we haven't done
so now is that this is
not a standard yet.
So we want to make sure that
when we implement it, we want
to implement a standard, so that
it actually works across
all of the devices.
So we want to make sure, you
know, you don't have to worry
about this, it should
just work.
And if we do implement Wi-Fi
Direct, we'll just hide it
behind the same API.
So to you guys, it will
just be transparent.
It'll just work.
Something else really important,
which I hear a lot,
NFC uses a lot of power.
You see this on a lot
of forums, or
people say that it does.
So first of all, when you phone
is off or when your
phone is locked, the NFC
controller is not even enabled.
So at that point, it's
not really consuming
any power at all.
Even when your phone is
unlocked, and so we enable the
NFC controller, still, only,
power is minimal.
It's like, compared to all the
rest, it's, like, 0.5% of
battery usage.
So it doesn't really
amount to anything.
You can safely leave it on.
Because if you turn it off,
it really breaks the magic
because then you will have to
go into the menu settings
again and enable NFC to
make stuff happen.
It's much easier to
just leave it on.
You really won't notice
in your battery usage.
Also, NFC controllers in the
future will use less power, so
I think it's getting
better and better.
So summarizing what we
talked about today.
The first thing is
really important,
NFC is here to stay.
A lot of people discussed this
also, when are the NFC devices
coming out.
It's happening right now.
We see one million NFC devices
activated every week, which is
a huge number.
There is a lot of growth
in that number as well.
The second thing we wanted to
share with you is that adding
NFC to your applications
is very easy.
You just add a few lines of
code, and automatically, the
operating system will take care
of the rest, sharing it,
sending it across NFC,
and dealing with it
on the other side.
It's so easy, and it really adds
value to your application
to do stuff like this.
And finally, the new J API
is really awesome.
I mean, you just have to write
a few lines of code, and you
can automatically send across
any file on the file system or
any data from a content provider
to the other side,
not having to worry about any
pairing or setup or--
just bring the devices together,
tap, and the file
automatically gets
sent across.
It's awesome.
All right, I'm going to hand off
to Robert, who's going to
talk to you about a Beam file.
ROBERT: Yeah so I guess I should
add just a quick legal
disclaimer, this is not
available if you're watching
the repeat on YouTube.
But for those in the room, who's
got the Google I/O app?
Most of you, I hope.
We actually put a little Easter
egg-- thank you we've
already got a winner
down there--
we put a little Easter egg
for you in the app.
So if you grab your app, and
you beam, you will add an
item, sorry, there, you will see
an extra new item in your
menu which says, show Android
Beam Easter egg.
Which looks kind of like that.
And if you come up and see us
afterwards, we'll give you a
limited-edition Beam pin.
We have just about enough for
everyone, but they are only
available here today, so
do come and grab them.
We just wanted to make sure that
everyone had tried Beam
and everyone had used it.
So it was just a bit of
fun for today, so
sorry YouTube viewers.
Come and find me at my
desk, and maybe I'll
have some pins left.
So yeah, that wraps it up.
We want to move on to Q&A. So
there we go, there's just a
reminder so that you
can see that.
And yeah, let's take any
questions about Beam or NFC.
And thanks very much for
listening, for those of you
that don't have questions.
There are microphones.
It's probably easier if you
come and grab a mic.
And we'll do we can to answer.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the--
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT: Thanks.
Oh, very orderly queue-forming,
thank you.
OK, first question.
AUDIENCE: Do the Bluetooth
radios have to be on for the
Beam APIs to work?
MARTIN: That's a
great question.
Actually, we do turn it on
for you automatically.
ROBERT: Could you repeat it to
make sure everybody can hear?
MARTIN: Yeah.
So the question was, does
Bluetooth already need to be
on for the APIs to work?
That's actually not required.
So if Bluetooth is off at the
moment of the transfer, we
automatically enable
it for you.
When the transfer is done
we turn it off again.
So you don't have to worry about
turning Bluetooth on
before the transfer.
It just works.
ROBERT: We take care of it.
Next one, hi.
AUDIENCE: Is there any way to
have Bluetooth as a backup if
there is not NFC?
ROBERT: So is there any way to
have Bluetooth as a backup if
there isn't NFC?
ROBERT: Or use some of the same
APIs without having to
recode it for a separate
Bluetooth.
MARTIN: Not right now.
I think in case of that, you
would have to use the normal
actions and the APIs to
get the data across.
ROBERT: Hi, next one.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Underlying that, are you using
the 2.1 insecure pair in the
background?
Or is there some sort of PIN
happening in the background?
MARTIN: This is the
implementation of the
Bluetooth Secure Simple
Pairing setup.
ROBERT: Thanks.
MARTIN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: The Bluetooth
pairing is fantastic.
Is it possible to establish a
serial-style connection, and
do you guys provide any
example code for
that in the new SDK?
MARTIN: Not with the
current API.
So right now we just allow you
to automatically set up OBEX
push for file transfer.
But it doesn't allow any
other sockets yet.
But it's something we may
look into in the future.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
We already added NFC
in our application.
You can test on Beautiful
Widgets and Plume.
But we have to add the intent
action, NFC_DISCOVERED.
Is there a way to share a normal
ACTION_VIEW intent?
MARTIN: So for NDEF, there isn't
because NDEF is a very
specific payload format.
So this just works for the
new Bluetooth APIs.
ROBERT: Bless you.
We have rules.
MARTIN: Should we move the
Q&A somewhere else?
ROBERT: Yeah keep going with the
Q&A. And if you kind of go
this way to do pins because we
want to do Q&A. Because this
is important, and we can
do pins outside.
So please keep the
questions going.
And try and stay quiet
down in front, so the
Q&A guys get their--
AUDIENCE: Sure, my question's
about Beam and compatibility
with non-Android devices.
Is that possible?
Are those just NDEF messages
standard, NDEF messages coming
across to establish the
Beam connection?
MARTIN: That's a
good question.
So we implemented all of the NFC
Forum standards for each
of these things.
So NDEF is one of these
standards, but also, for doing
the actual data transfer,
there's a protocol called
SNEP, which is Simple NDEF
Exchange Protocol, which
allows you to send across
NDEF messages.
And this is a standardized
protocol as well.
So all of these devices that
implement this protocol, it's
an open protocol, will be
able to receive beams.
In effect, we've seen Beam
already interplay well with,
for example, RIM devices.
And the same goes for the
Bluetooth pairing.
There is a standard for that by
NFC Forum as well, so, for
example, passing on
a Mac address.
So everybody who implements the
standard should be able to
get this Bluetooth connection
going and send data across.
So it's all based
on standards.
AUDIENCE: So a follow-up
question to that is, you talk
about the seamless experience
of doing a
beam between two devices.
And it's my feeling that tapping
the screen is really
an extra piece of friction
that's not necessary, from
being that you wouldn't
necessarily put two devices
that close in proximity to
each other if you didn't
intend to exchange data.
And I'm just wondering if that's
something that could be
removed or is being considered
to be configurable, at least.
MARTIN: Yeah, I think
the short-range
stage is a bit there.
If you play with a Nexus 7 and a
different phone, you'll find
that you actually need to be
careful with the positioning
to make Beam work.
So in most cases, if you put
something on top, you actually
won't see any beam.
You just need to put it
in the right spot.
But we could think of more
advanced stuff, like if we
detect that there's an NFC
connection, we could, for
example, disable the touch
screen so it doesn't react
anymore to any input events.
So that's something that we
may consider in that case.
But that's not currently done.
AUDIENCE: In one of your demos,
you showed, basically,
Beam or NFC muting one
of your test devices.
So you had a tag that muted
the phones' notifications.
I'm wondering if there's any
need security considerations
going into that.
Like, maybe somebody put a tag
somewhere that mutes phones,
and you didn't really
want that to happen.
Is there going to be an API at
some point that says, you
know, do you really
want to do this?
MARTIN: I should point out that
these tag actions only
work if you have the application
installed
to deal with them.
So that's already a bit.
And for this specific
application, I know they
actually pop up a notification
saying that
they activated something.
So you do have a clue that
something is ongoing.
So I think it's a careful
trade-off, right.
Maybe you don't want to ruin the
magic by allowing people
to confirm.
So I think, in most use cases,
the trade-off is right.
You'll see something
is going on.
And if it's wrong, I think
you'll catch wind of it.
ROBERT: How's the Q&A
going, Martin?
I'm a bit tied up here.
MARTIN: Pretty good.
ROBERT: Cool.
MARTIN: Lots of queuing here.
ROBERT: So guys, I'm going
to change tacks slightly.
I'm assuming I can trust
all of you, right?
Don't take a handful of pins.
Just take one.
And, please, if you do an take
more than one, because you
can't be trusted, you must beam
someone else who hasn't
beamed and give them
one of the pins.
How does that sound
for a deal?
Is that fair?
So if you take two, make sure
you give one to someone
tonight, spread the love,
and let's do Q&A.
So I'm going to put
the pins here.
It will be a free-for-all.
Please don't crush each other,
we value every one of our
developers, we can't
afford to lose you.
MARTIN: There's enough
for everybody.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I've got a
very related question.
We're working on secure payments
and was wondering if
you have any security
requirements for NFC
specifically.
MARTIN: Sorry, could you
repeat the question?
AUDIENCE: We're working on
secure payments and was
wondering if Google has
security requirements
pertaining to NFC side.
MARTIN: So I think what we'd
have you do is, it depends on
how you implement
the payments.
If you wanted to implement
it over peer-to-peer, for
example, the Android Beam
protocol that we have, you
need to do some encryption
of yourself.
Because by default the channel
is unencrypted, right?
So if it's your own application,
I mean, Google
doesn't set any requirements.
But I think it would be wise
to actually encrypt your
traffic yourself and do some
form of identification to make
sure that nobody can actually
eavesdrop it.
I mean, it's really hard because
of the close range,
but still I think it's a good
idea to put some kind of
encryption and authentication
in these sensitive cases.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MARTIN: Does that answer
your question, or--
AUDIENCE: Yep.
MARTIN: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi, you showed in
one of the demos where you
were able to write multiple
actions onto a passive tag.
Does that work with passive tags
from any manufacturer and
of any type, or is there a
specific manufacturer that
supports this?
MARTIN: So the question was, if
the task launch demo that I
showed that has multiple
actions, if it works will all
of the tags.
So Android supports all of the
standard NFC forum tag types,
which is tag type 1 to 4,
if you're familiar.
So if you buy any of
these tags, it
should work with that.
So they come in different sizes,
but most of the popular
tag types are supported.
AUDIENCE: OK, you can write
multiple actions to any of the
standards supported.
MARTIN: Any of the standard
tags will work.
AUDIENCE: Hi, the Bluetooth
pairing, the connection
handover that you just showed,
is it NFC Forum
standard-based?
Does it follow the NFC
Forum standard?
MARTIN: Yeah so it's based on
the NFC Forum connection
handover specification, which
standardizes the way the MAC
address and the PIN
is exchanged.
ROBERT: We really hope that
other platforms will pick up
and do exactly the same thing
because that's just going to
make it easy for users.
AUDIENCE: OK, great.
And when are you going to open
card emulation to developers,
at any point?
MARTIN: Yeah, it's a popular
question still.
We just haven't found the
right way to expose card
emulation and APIs
to our users.
I think, when we do, we want
to have a consistent set of
APIs and experiences.
So one of the issues with card
emulation is that not even all
devices have the secure
elements.
Which, I think, makes
it harder.
And also, it has a limited
amount of storage.
So that means, for example, if
your storage is full, and you
want to do some exchange, you
actually need to remove
something and stuff something
new in there.
And it basically destroys
the entire interaction.
So I think, for the current
use cases that we have,
Android Beam is actually a
really promising direction.
And card emulation I see more as
something to interact with
the legacy reader infrastructure
that we have in
place, right?
That's really what
it's good for.
But right now, because the
experience you have with card
emulation is very fragmented,
it's hard to get it to work,
we don't want to offer any APIs
because that would just
get users frustrated that it
doesn't work sometimes,
sometimes it does.
It's hard to get it right.
AUDIENCE: All right,
thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
We work for a ticketing company,
and integrating the
NFC check-in is really
something we
are interested in.
The thing is, the Beam checking
and this star field
effect is kind of something
that is
slowing down the check-in.
So are you guys considering
giving us the ability to just
get rid of it, or what are
the plans on that?
MARTIN: Good question, it's
definitely something we're
looking into.
So the question was, if we can
speed up the beam process for
ticketing, or you really just
want to tap something and walk
on without having
to tap anything.
Yeah, we will definitely
look into this
for the next release.
As far as I'm concerned, it's
part of the two-way
communication protocol
and customizing Beam.
So there may be a use case
where, actually, you just tap,
and immediately the data link
is established, and your
application can deal with it.
So we know it's an important use
case, and we'll definitely
look into future APIs
to do just that.
AUDIENCE: Awesome, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Again, sort of
a security question.
The 5 centimeters, is that
reliable, or are there ways,
you know, the Pringles can, to
get around that and read it
more remotely?
AUDIENCE: It's really hard
to get around it.
I guess if you have a really
sensitive directional antenna,
and you would be able to aim it
right at it, then it could
be possible.
But I think it's, in practice,
really hard.
And also, most of the use cases,
you just have your
phone in your pocket, right?
So at that point NFC
is not enabled.
So it's really hard to
get the data from it.
So I think, in practice, you
could get a larger range if
you have really expensive
equipment, but it's not
something to worry
about in general.
AUDIENCE: OK, and then sort
of a second question.
Bluetooth low energy,
do Android phones
also support that?
And maybe the Nordic 2.4
gigahertz protocol
that's used by Fitbit?
MARTIN: I'm not sure
about what our
plans are for low energy.
I think it's different, compared
to NFC, in the sense
that Bluetooth low energy
still has a large range.
So you still pick up multiple
devices, or you still have to
select the device that you want
to interact with, right?
And the great thing about NFC
is you can tap something to
determine that you want
to interact with it.
So I think that's the main
difference between Bluetooth
LE and NFC at this point.
ROBERT: All of those radio
technologies can combine
together to do really
interesting stuff.
And I think that's one of the
great things about having an
open platform is can weave use
cases, and create new things
that no one's ever thought
of by using
those things together.
So we don't see one of those
technologies prevalent over
the others.
We want them all available
to you guys.
We've got an API so that
you can make magic.
AUDIENCE: Does or will Chromebug
support NFC?
MARTIN: I don't think they do.
ROBERT: I don't think Chromebugs
do support--
I don't think there are any that
have been announced to
date that support NFC.
But it's great to put a tag on
your laptop, and then you can
do all sorts of things you
can use that, so it's a
good use for a tag.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
For devices to support the
Bluetooth pairing via NFC, do
Bluetooth device driver
need to be updated?
MARTIN: So what we depend on,
basically, is the existing
protocol stack in Android, the
OPP protocol stack for
Bluetooth, because it uses
the OPP protocol.
I think, actually, most
OEMS take the
stack as is from Android.
I don't think they have, like,
a custom OPP stack in there.
But OEM vendors that do replace
the NFC stack, they
will actually need to
write some code that
allows them to do this.
The main thing is basically
about bypassing the UI because
normally, when you do Bluetooth
OPP file transfer,
you get a lot of confirmations,
a lot of
changes that you
need to make--
I mean, a lot of confirmations
you need to do.
So the main thing, really, that
we changed in OPP is that
to determine if the transfer
came from NFC and if it was
NFC-initiated, don't do all of
this confirmation, but just
make the magic happen.
So those are in there--
ROBERT: Sorry, we're actually
out of time.
So we'll take the rest of the
questions up here, so we'll
take them offline.
Thanks very much.
MARTIN: We'll also be in office
hours, by the way.
ROBERT: Sorry?
MARTIN: We'll be in
office hours.
ROBERT: We will be in office
hours, yeah and in bars all
over San Francisco.
But yeah, thanks for coming to
the "Up Close and Personal"
with Android NFC.
And go make magic with
Android Beam.
Thanks, guys.